voters Kerry Lake joins us tonight Kelly
thank you so much for coming on did you
I mean I I assume you must have
suspected something like this was
happening how do you feel now that it's
been confirmed
well nothing surprises me now to be
honest but this did I was a little bit
surprised I mean we saw what happened
with Hunter's laptop in 2020 the dnc's
behind it Biden's people are behind it
keeping the narrative away from
discussing the disturbing contents of
that so it shouldn't be surprising that
states are doing this and my opponent
who I wanted to recuse herself from the
election a year more than a year ago
because of conflict of interest it
wouldn't surprise me if her office was
trying to silence people I mean we got
silenced at one point my Twitter page
got taken down because they didn't like
one of the tweets I put up during the
election it makes me wonder who was
behind that we had to remove a tweet
during the election in order to get our
ability to communicate with our
followers and the people who were
supporting us it is frightening what's
happening with Twitter this is an arm
it's a propaganda arm of our government
and we need to wake up right now and and
demand that we get some control over
what's happening in our government the
FBI and you know we're talking about
Twitter tonight let's talk Facebook what
about Tick Tock this thing is going to
go so deep that I think people are going
to be shocked when they learn the full
extent I can't wait to hear what they
were doing when it comes to censoring us
on covet When people's lives were at
risk when our children were being masked
up shocking
and with vaccines really quick how can
you have a democracy in a country where
the government is suppressing speech how
can that be a democratic country
I believe it's called fascism and
they're always accusing us of being the
fascist one and you know they they spent
three years talking about Russia Russia
Russia the collusion story and they
didn't want to talk about a hunter's
laptop they didn't want to talk about
problems with our elections that we
discovered in 2020 and we saw repeated
in 22. when are we going to have a
serious discussion about what's really
wrong in this country we don't have a
lot of time left on the clock and you
know as Twitter said what was the what
was the first the term they used were on
it we're going to get on it right away
but we're getting on it in Arizona and
the people have had enough we're sick of
of the uh Katie Hobbs office and the
Secretary of State's office and what
they've been up to and we're going to
start fighting back and we're going to
be drawing up some lawsuits in our
election because we won't have elections
that are run like the run in third world
countries we have too much to save in
this country to allow our elections to
be run that way well godspeed I I think
all P I think I would hope all people
would agree with that Kerry Lake great
to see you tonight thank you
thanks subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight